we're going to begin with this because
we like saying only on cbs this morning
i'll say it twice only on cbs this
morning former first lady michelle obama
she's revealing what's next in her fight
to give all families did you hear that
part
all families access to healthy food
she's got the help of two quirky and
adorable puppets their names are waffles
and mochi
they star in her netflix show which
teaches kids about healthy food
mrs obama is the executive producer and
appears in every episode
their latest campaign pass the love with
waffles and mochi
will provide healthy food to families
nationwide who may not have the
resources or access to supplies
today mrs obama and the partnership for
a healthier america
are announcing their first target cities
for that initiative cleveland and
atlanta
we met up with the former first lady in
washington recently to talk about why
she's so excited about the project
and what drew her to waffles and mochi
in the first place
if you want to be great chefs you have
to learn about all kinds of different
foods
and that's just one of the messages
behind michelle obama's netflix show
waffles and mochi oh hello waffles and
mochi are you ready for an amazing
adventure
the show teaches kids the value of
healthy eating and features key themes
of diversity and inclusion
as waffles and mochi travel the globe
and learn about new culinary traditions
wow it's like a rainbow in my mouth
along the way
waffles and mochi are guided by their
mentor a supermarket manager
played by you guessed it michelle obama
these are tomatoes and i just picked
them fresh from the garden
after i read the the concept i thought
this
is going to be so good so i wanted to be
a part of it but
but you don't have to be i didn't have
to be but you know i asked the question
it's like look i don't want to be
mrs o if there's a better mrs zoe out
there who's the better mrs oh
let's think about that for a second but
i had to tell him gail i am not an
actor um so i was like don't give me a
bunch of lines so
it was it was fun because i could be
impromptu
and working with waffles and mochi i
love the fact that we're also trying to
find
a purpose in it because that's still
something that's important to me we've
gotta have courage moshi or we'll never
really learn how to cook
it sends a message beyond food and fun
you know there's always a theme about
love and acceptance and openness it's
just a gentle reminder
to young kids we want to teach them this
rare gift of empathy and now that
mission continues
with the former first lady's pass the
love initiative
waffles and mochi have teamed up with
the partnership for a healthier america
to provide meal kits to families in need
inspired by recipes from the show
and today mrs obama is announcing the
first target cities
you know we looked at cities where there
were there was need
and many of our urban uh areas are have
been struggling under covid so we could
have gone to any
city um but atlanta and cleveland were
sort of primed for this partnership
and we want to bring attention to the
fact that
in 2021 is that what year yeah i know
i know yeah it's 20 21 yeah that people
are still
hungry in one of the richest nations on
earth
and we're going to provide we're going
to provide 1 million meals
to families in need all across the
country so they're going to get little
food packages
that are waffles and mochi specials
where they'll have the ingredients and
the recipes
easy affordable they get it free but
they also
find out that they can go back to the
stores and do this again
and all these meal kits are going to be
healthy so that all families can follow
along with the recipes
my children are now 34 and 35.
and i i wish you know cooking is not my
forte i look at how they were raised on
spaghettios
fish sticks tater tots yeah and if i had
a regret about parenting that would be
it but we were growing
up we were raising our kids in a
different time you know when they're
when we didn't free me mrs obama yeah
but when we didn't know that all the
quick fast
options were not that healthy yeah it's
true
we didn't know that yeah it's true so
that's why the education pieces
is important because we can't beat
ourselves up for stuff we didn't know
and now more and more families
understand this and that they also
can see that they can cook an affordable
meal
quickly save money and time
in the years since her family left the
white house mrs obama could have taken
some well-earned time
off but she told us she does not take
for granted the reach of her voice
and the unique platform of a former
first lady
i'm 57 barack will be 60 this year we
still have a lot of life left
and so to sit by you know when you see
all the need and all the stuff that
needs to be done
we still feel like we have a
responsibility to be engaged
in in this planet i mean i'm still not
working at the pace i was working
um i can i still have more freedom to do
the things that i want i'm knitting now
i'm doing oh it's sofia no you're
knitting
i know that sounds no disrespect but it
sounds very old lady
it was surprised but you know it's sort
of me because
i like creating something out of nothing
it's not
old lady i don't want you to come for my
knitting community again
i know that's why i want to be very
that's why i said no disrespect don't
get me started
because i don't want to bore people with
my little knitting i may barack a
sweater a crew neck sweater
has he worn it he will it was finished
when it got a little warmer um so it's
ready for him i made halter tops for
malia and sasha that they love
there's something special about this
yeah to know that mom made this for me
so the point being is that there's time
to do it all there's still plenty of
time
to continue to work on issues that
matter
without sort of being in the middle of
it and let me tell you it helps to have
our president joe biden in office
because
you know when you have a responsible
mature president in
office it makes it even easier for us
to move on to the the next phases of the
work that we do
because we're not sitting and worrying
every day about what's going to happen
next
but there's still plenty of time to do
some good
plenty of time to do some good she's
right about that i can't say enough
about that waffles and mochi show
because
in preparation i said i'm gonna watch
one episode just to get a sense of it so
i'll start with tomatoes
then before i know i go well let me see
what's going on with the eggs and the
pickles and the salt
it's really good we watched the
saltwater i was making some minestrone
soup and teddy and mom are watching it
upstairs
and then they came down and you know dad
over salted the suit of the soup i'll be
honest and teddy can't really express
that yet but i swear he watched the
episode he took the bite of the soup he
looked at me like
dad you blew it it's very
educational it really is for instance
okay what's a tomato is it a fruit or a
vegetable
quick anthony uh it's a it's a vegetable
it's a fruit
it's got seeds it's a fruit because it's
got very good i know it was a trick
question
inside but it's used as a vegetable
mostly it's just a tomato that's but
it's got all sorts of little interesting
things like that that i think are very
helpful and they travel all around the
world it was just so
well i love that the first lady is
knitting i think that's really cool
i just think i think that's a very
therapeutic thing to do no it's
really good for the mind yeah you can
learn to cook now
you can learn to knit you've got so much
in your future as she said though guys
don't come from my knitting community
oh no they'll come they're a very big
group no they've got needles too so be
careful they got needles
and tomorrow night that's right you can
watch former first lady michelle obama
where's she going to be she's going to
buy you on the late show with stephen
colbert
i'm really curious to see what the two
of them do that'll be right here on cbs